up first we got jack steele this is jack
steele
great name a rat king a big brown we got
a debate club for you today
that's racist water slides or coasters
of rollers
me myself big roller coaster guy i like
them
slides boy we be slipping and sliding
out here
boys on them hey gang buzz buzz my high
friends
um roller coasters or water slides
which one is it uh i'm not a big water
slide
fan to be honest with you a little
traumatized as a young man on a water
slide
but the water slide also it's such a
hassle at those water parks
you gotta have the aqua socks on those
things suck you're on the sun all
goddamn day
you're eating funnel cakes and sugar
next you know you're on the lazy river
it's a nightmare what are we talking
about we're talking about water slides
or roller coasters bro
and one time i was at a water park right
and it was but when they first
came out you know when they had like the
tidal wave and you could surf it
well i decided to get on that i was
young and i got on there and the thing
shot me out and ripped my pants off my
shorts
and the entire park's on my dick piece
yeah my dad tried chasing me so i bet it
took him a while to see it too
no everyone was like it's a snake
there's a coral snake in the water
no that waiter swam up with a tray i bet
he works at a waiter park i bet no scuba
gear required
um what is up with these guys are they
stoned it seems like they're a little
drunk yeah that boy is a little drugged
up
debate clubs lettuce let me see water
slides
dude water slides uh good way to catch
herpes
here was a crazy thing i remember
growing up they had a water slide at
this place lando pines campground
and somebody would do diarrhea on the
slide oh and then here's what they would
do here's the heroes of the move
they would shut the pool down for five
minutes at the bottom everybody would
get out
then they would just have us go again
like that
cleaned everything up and they had
turtles they had or they had a big pond
right next
like a just a natural pond like just a
little like a
you know like a very very little bitty
lake you know
and he had some redneck turtles in there
huh they're the ones with the red i'm
not saying
derogatory term but they're turtles with
bread on their neck oh yeah
yeah they had turtles yeah they'd have a
turtle with a damn mullet in there you
know
and uh nascar number on this show
oh man small hands in the back you know
turtles in the front turtles in the back
wet boys and then somebody get a turtle
and take it down the slide with them
and leave it in the pool at the bottom
of the slide was an actual pool when
people get pissed in there
turtles don't do well in chlorine it was
fun though man it was exciting and uh
what was the name of the place lando
pines and then you get you a
one of them barks root beer is the red
root beer and your whole mouth would get
stained red and your whole face even
when you were a kid [ __ ] yeah
and then you would just want you'd be
freezing cold after you got out of the
water slide you know
and just drinking that barks and just
get your lips all red and you just
wander off into the woods that's
living brother pedophiles that's living
though brother chucking and diving them
pedophiles but that's living i didn't
have the pedophiles but that's living
but you send a cold kid back there with
[ __ ] almost lipstick on his mouth
dude from that barks red soda bro
the jit point and the kids trying to
warm up oh yeah pedophiles trying to get
off
crime in the front pedophiles in the
front
paddy's in the back but yeah these guys
i think you got to go roller coasters
man i don't like having to put on the
you know the the the the wet clothes and
do all of that
such a hassle and that the wet socks
yeah the spongies
the other thing is roller coaster one's
not staying with the six flags yeah they
need to chill out on that [ __ ] i don't
need to be on a goddamn
stealth jet front row with barely any
protection
yeah it's ripping my [ __ ] face it's
turned into seven flags you didn't see
and iran i think is the seventh flag
because that shit's getting heated over
there
it's too much one of them it's like you
had to shoot your buddy with a [ __ ]
grenade launcher it's like that's way
dude why are you just jumping out of the
plane hoping someone catches you yeah
let's go back to six flags dude you know
dude it'll be more peaceful it's intense
i i
i'll be honest i went there a year ago i
had to i told him i was scared of one i
told my girl
not happening yeah which is why i went i
don't feel good but really i'm scared
and some of the rides are getting real
wimpy too like the big bang theory ride
and it's just like you and your friends
just like sit around a coffee table and
kind of complain for a little bit
like this isn't really this isn't fun
yeah six flags is the [ __ ] though but
they need to chill out man they take it
down a notch
well they used to have better rides too
they used to have leprosy remember that
thing you get on there and you get off
with a disease or something
yeah they used to have the ct wagon
we're just bumbling around
yeah man i missed some of the overrides
but i'm going to go roller coasters all
day it keeps you dry
if you guys especially if you got a kid
and they got a diaper on and stuff and
you got to take them off of the water
park into the place and everybody's wet
and everything
[ __ ] their pants and stuff yeah yeah
roller coasters all day
yeah all day 51 went roller coasters as
well
damn that was a close battle psychos
i was so tight i wonder i thought that
was a
landslide for roller coasters water park
that shit's exhausting
yeah lazy river get the [ __ ] out of my
face man what about
daughter parks dude some 50 year old guy
bringing their daughter out some 24 year
old dying piece it's called a trailer
park
for trailers you delinquent
[Music]
is